trazido de ouro em 32 o que falar andar
que sejam muito bem vindos a mais 1
bilhão e os planos de que a superfície
gigantes de ouro e com foco mas
estávamos aqui um vídeo então busca de
ouro e bater para o mundo vai precisar
muito light mesmo compreende a meta dos
100 mil likes por também estão os
enviados não quero mostrar ela morrido
mas vai que é muito bacana social caiu e
19 no ambiente secreto lei 8.630 massa
vai ter quatro filhos para mil ea
segunda é muita pedra e namisa não
perder a nota diz a claude que você
quiser adotar uma meta mas conseguiu
chegar ao fazer uma mega baixa de 4 de
ouro polido o qual venho é que o partiu
de buenos grande hotel
[Música]
o ovo é muito mole
o dólar está muito grandes ainda falta
mais de 12 quilos mata
os príncipes em quatro bolas quicando
bom é uma subida agora o trabalho mais
difícil vai ser uma sala estudo
acreditarem que eles tenham vontade de
matá lo possível e nega a música massa
deu a volta com uma pequena confusão
porque a massa estava há algum tempo vai
para mais uma em uma hora do estaleiro
fazer os quatro dias podendo e já
identificada ainda estamos a tentar
captar mais não é um ok
o próximo passo agora é dobrar as pontas
na época pisa tem aquela para fora que
ele possui mais mas é mais um pão tanto
trabalho já não estava em uma pista
tempo não sai de sua massa pronta e
agora vamos escutar apesar de 14 cadu
não quatro casos importados
mas não era do paul corta muito rápido
só que eu vou tentar fazer é explorar o
alumínio porque nós vamos parar as
quatro pistas por dente por cima que é
preciso mais fácil ir à urna
então parece complicado mas é quase isso
ok entendi a primeira fatia fala
primeira tentativa pronta e não só os
quatro dias da tua disparada não vai ser
mais fácil agora tombar o turno e agora
é a parte mais emotiva senkaku são hora
de colocar os ingredientes é fácil
chegar a um bom vôlei do hífen
basta colocar o tomate assim e agora é
só pegar ó só pegada mas será assim
[Música]
augusto mata e eu acho que está com foco
em galinhas queijo mostraram que o
estudante nessa casa eu acho que quanto
à embalagem chega mas mas o v
[Música]
ninguém gosta de 45 para despedirem vai
muito além da indústria em kapisa
eu acho que nós compramos bacana mas
falta mais um dos vizinhos que é muito
confortável mas enquanto isso vou ficar
aqui o povo já a crescer é agora eu não
sei como foi em games mas vou tentar não
sei
[Música]
agora vamos colocar o nosso molho de
coco saiu eu sei que parece um pouco
estranho merece muito qualquer fica
muito bom em piso até o experimento
diferente mas não basta é bom é bom e
andré có ainda espera portuguesa é má
gestão e falta de pessoal aqui da nossa
expectativa é um impacto não é tão bom
quanto ao colocar a nossa surpresa na
foto
[Música]
conceição conferência em que eu cheguei
em casa mas depois de dez minutos para
conversar por conversar muito o olho
pouco fala massa tá muito depositar
mandar um ser bem bom tem que ficar um
pouco mais mas já te digo uma fantasia
pronta a massa parou quando o bai cantar
no fundo o molho está num ponto agora
faltou o toque especial que a pintura de
ouro que é nossa feito escreve o papa
a mulher fugiu
pizza pronta para lá será queimado
tá doido as palavras e descobrindo agora
é só pintar de ouro né
[Música]
low tech desta quinta não tem seguro
portanto podem comer à vontade isto é
que não podia ter acontecido nem acho
que pintar a medida do hotel e não errou
não só vou pintar agora apresentadora
estava na moto roubada e eu comprei
esporte em especial é um pouco em
dourados mais brilhante para tal muito
brilhante resultado ficar bonito eu vou
contar o valor em todas as coisas fizer
de ouro tanto né
está aqui um pouquinho na colher
o ouro em 32 o palco ficou no altar
muito seguro o 1 0 o bayern então vai
ter um duro lei mesmo que nada importa
em uma tábua mesmo banho
eu só comi o pão é a que mais mata foi o
[Música]
que nós não ter tanto né
a casa que tem embaixo coisas de ouro e
r 100 mil mas eu vou poder então o nosso
padrão não podem